the potential impact of the weather is
causing anxiety for thousands of people
who live in Southern California red flag
and fire warnings are in effect in much
of the state Jamie yuccas is in Agoura
Hills just west of Los Angeles talking
with homeowners who don't want to be
forced out of their homes again Jamie I
can understand good morning good morning
high winds could reignite flames and
bring danger back to this area to those
who have survived the fire so far
they're hoping to not experience a
nightmare like this father's you can
just get with your shoe
Alex Orbison stops out hot spots near
one of his homes in Malibu after the so
called woolsey fire scorched his
neighborhood
the flames reach right up the back of
his home the flames were like 50 feet
tall and you can see him from the street
behind us Orbison evacuated his family
but came back with others to try and
protect what's left with the forecast
that winds are picking back up are you
nervous
well I'm worrying about my property and
I'm more worried about my neighbors
Linda and Johnny Castellano lost their
home in Oak Park when it was hit twice
by the so called Hill Fire and Ventura
once on Thursday and then again on
Saturday when the fire reignited I was
running and it was dry and I had no
water
we met Matt Armbruster on Friday covered
in mud after a close call with the
woolsey fire when the fire approached
his home he panicked and ran to a nearby
creek I was in the water right here
laying flat in this water did you think
you were gonna die of course
and then after literally about 35 or 40
seconds of extreme intense heat it
started a subside it went past and then
it was just like crackling and burning
it
our Bursar's house did survive but he's
keeping a hose nearby just in case
flames kick back up to survivors who
will try to rebuild they may have to do
it without modern technology there's no
internet cell service or electricity
here and it may not come back for weeks
John Jamie thank you